[Musica]
avevo circa 5 anni quando mia madre mi
fece la classica domanda che si fa tutti
i bambini che cosa vuoi fare da grande
io risposi due cose la prima era che
volevo disegnare per la disney e in
particolare topolino perché come molti
di voi qui in platea io ero il lettore
del mercoledì la seconda era che volevo
fare l'archeologo ma nello specifico
indiana jones con l'indiana jones ora il
primo sogno io l'ho realizzato mi reputo
abbastanza fortunato sul secondo ancora
ci sto lavorando per o meno del tempo
anche perché l'avete visto che indiana
jones ultimamente è stato a cefalù che
girare il nuovo episodio di indiana
benissimo quando io comincio i miei
incontri pubblici faccio sempre una
domanda che voglio fare anche a voi
ed è questa secondo voi cos'è
assolutamente essenziale per l'esistenza
degli esseri umani
mangiare dormire
respirare
meno male che non avete risposto le
storie se non mi rovinate anche qual è
la sorpresa del nuovo pug bene le storie
sono assolutamente essenziali non ci
pensiamo mai lo diamo per scontato ma se
ci pensate un attimino
la nostra storia arriva sulla terra
prima che noi siamo qui
quando i nostri genitori ci aspettano
immaginano come saremo che cosa cosa
faremo da grandi cosa sognano per noi
e ogni giorno nella nostra testa noi non
facciamo altro che rivederci sempre
delle storie
pensate il secondo dove vado chi sono
come mi chiamo cosa voglio fare cosa
voglio mangiare stasera appena esco da
qui tutta questa roba qua
questo concetto che è assolutamente
essenziale lo vedremo stasera parlando
di fumetti era assolutamente chiaro a un
popolo saggio quanto antico che sono gli
aborigeni
ora voi mi direte ma che c'entrano gli
aborigeni studiando incontro del ted
c'entrano allora potete una cosa
piuttosto strana ma interessante e cioè
che quello che stiamo vivendo adesso
quella che noi definiamo in realtà
non esiste un sogno questo che siamo in
un sogno ad occhi aperti lo dicevo anche
per paolo pasolini il suo film
bellissimo che cosa sono le nuvole
ed erano convinti che questo sogno si
dovesse raccontare altrimenti il mondo
sarebbe finito vedere talmente
importante che loro girano l'australia e
raccontano le storie dei loro antenati
ora sembrerebbe un po strano no una cosa
del genere se non fosse vera
perché dovete sapere che se questo
incontro magari
vi piacerà ci perde un punto dai
racconti degli articoli ne parlerete
questo mi è piaciuto di più quello che
facevo di meno però continuerà a
esistere però se questo incontro
non vi piacerà e ci può stare e non me
ne frega niente e ci può stare e non
devo avere più tra 5 10 50 anni 100 anni
non sarà mai esistito io vi faccio
sempre la domanda su cosa è successo in
questo luogo che non è stato raccontato
che nessuno dovrà mai alla fine no
per cui raccontare per esistere ed è
assolutamente fondamentale questo
concetto bene
un'altra domanda che faccio e se la
gente a creatività voi avete creatività
fantasia
molti mi dicono hai o non riesco a
immaginare niente non mi chiedere non mi
viene chiuso disegnare un po per niente
adesso facciamo un giochino
un gioco interattivo
dovete chiudere gli occhi
chiude tria vi chiedo pure io cominci a
chiudere gli occhi rimango qua non mi
muovo non vi preoccupate nessuno fa
niente ok
immaginate
di essere un gorilla
siamo un gorilla
guardate le vostre mani sono callose
pelosa come quelle di un gorilla
siamo seduti su un prato potete sentire
l'erba sotto di voi che vi solletica
la carta dove c'è la persona che amate
akesson gorilla sente una bellissima
radura potete sentire il canto degli
uccelli
vedere gli alberi intorno a voi
un punto a questo prato c'è fantastico
laguna laguna con una cascata
guardatela
se ne felici perché siete liberi siete
amati
a un tratto però la vostra attenzione
viene rapita da
uno strano silenzio
e più guardato intorno
e lì in fondo
vedete un gruppo di quelli che sembrano
essere dopo dei cacciatori armati
appena riguardate cominciano a urlare
contro di voi poi a parlare le persone
chiamate e corderia velocissimi senti
degli spari a un tratto però qualcosa mi
mordo la caviglia di alzate di colpo ma
c'è da avere addosso mi hanno colpito
comincerei ammirarli col per il primo
colpì del secondo ma certo tutto un
colpo in testa boom tutto buio
quando nel nostro
sogno
guardiamo di nuovo le nostre mani
stringono le sbarre donerà
in fondo a questa gabbia oltre c'è una
famiglia di turisti un ragazzino mangia
un pezzo di cheeseburger bello mangia
velo ma lancia vicine costruiti e di
volo quando te arrotolare non mi
interessa niente non porta siete tristi
la persona che amate e cantavo in
un'altra gabbia non vi potete toccare mi
hanno tolto la libertà
ma
questo è il nostro sogno
è nei sogni decidiamo noi cosa fare
per cento e se immaginiamo che le nostre
mani da gorilla
si trasformano lentamente in delle piume
diventiamo dei gabbiani noi la persona
che amiamo
volate volate attraverso le sbarre in
alto nel cielo di nuovo liberi
adesso avrete gli occhi
siete di nuovo qui siamo di nuovo qui
sul palco
avete visto gli alberi
la cascata
avete visti i cacciatori
e quando stavate scappando dai
cacciatori
eravate in soggettiva con la scena della
barca vate da fuori da dietro dall'alto
ecco poi dopo vi confronterete io ho
raccontato una sola storia ma ognuno di
voi ha visto un film diverso
sapete perché
perché tutti abbiamo creatività e
fantasia e siamo tutti i registi e siamo
tutti attori tutti scrittori
tutti i musicisti perché c'era anche la
musica perché gli uccelli non cantano
tutti alla stessa maniera
questo
è il mio lavoro
leggo una sceneggiatura
vede una scena prende un frame lo metto
sul foglio c'è un detto tutti che sono i
mistici
islamici molto bello che dice che il
segreto della felicità è quello di fare
una cosa che poi amate e che è utile per
gli altri ed è quello che voglio fare
per questa sera e cioè
dardi qualcosa che possa esservi utile
che possiate ricordarli io avevo la
necessità di fare in modo che le mie
storie fossero tangibili si potessero
toccare si potessero stringere si
potessero leggere e stasera vi voglio
spiegare com'è che
si scrive un fumetto
brevi cenni chiaramente che la prima
cosa è l'idea
l'idea io consiglio sempre di partire da
qualcosa che voi conoscete
da qualcosa che di emozione perché la
regola aurea anche se qualcosa di
emoziona e emozionerà anche il vostro
lettore o il vostro ascoltatore ok
partiamo dall'idea che l'abbiamo trovata
beh prima cosa
la documentazione fondamentale vogliamo
fare un fumetto ambientato a messina nel
seicento che troviamo tutto quello che
ci sia ad ambienti luoghi costumi ma
anche ricerca testuale come si
comportavano le persone del seicento
come era la città all
altra fase il soggetto e con molti non
sanno dei fumetti prima si scrivono poi
si disegnano il concerto è una specie di
riassunto per la quale se uno di voi qui
è il mio editore
titolo spiegare cos'è la storia brevi
cenni se il soggetto piace si passa la
sceneggiatura ora poi sicuramente
avrebbe fatto come me penso a scuola le
famose recite scolastiche
nelle recite scolastiche
cosa c'è c'è il copione
nel fumetto il copione che qui è diviso
per pagine e per vignette che sapete
cosa sono di quadrati in cui si vanno a
mettere le nostre di jenin dove viene
descritta la scena
questo libro che ho fatto insieme andate
per una nuova gara maggio alla ragazza
lo faccio vedere la seconda fase dopo la
sceneggiatura c'è la descrizione di
quello che c'è è il layout
lei a ottenere uno schizzo di quello che
sarà la pagina una cosa molto rapida per
dargli evidente poi dovete sapere che
lei auto storyboard viene utilizzato non
solo nel fumetto ma anche nel cinema
nella televisione videogiochi
dappertutto pensate che federico fellini
si faceva gli storyboard prima di girare
le scelte tutto viene disegnato prima
dopo di che andiamo alla tavola qui è
già finita colorata che è con la tavola
è fatta in varie fasi la prima fase e la
matita si disegna mattina la seconda
fase
el inchiostrazione ossia i contorni in
nero la terza fase è il colore
l'ultima fase
è il lettering che la fase in cui non
mettiamo il balloons e le nuvolette col
testo nella scelta
ora il fumetto siamo all unisono un
fumettista però il fumetto a tante
figure all'interno c'è lo sceneggiatore
colui che scrive il fumetto c'è il
disegnatore ma sapete che c'è anche link
illustratore il colorista che poi il
colore e ci sono anche letteristi che fa
le lettere che poverino e se li calcola
ma nessuno vi avessero che sono
fondamentali
benissimo
ora
una cosa assolutamente importante del
fumetto è che in un momento in cui la
gente ha sempre meno tempo lo vediamo
siamo sempre di corsa non abbiamo mai
tempo di leggere di stare a guardare
leggiamo solamente i titoli dei giornali
si approfondisce poco i ragazzi leggono
poco gli italiani leggono poco
il fumetto è un mezzo
fortissimo per raccontare delle
tematiche importanti come per esempio
parlare di
sé di fatto nelle scuole di immigrazione
di mafia di shoah i ragazzi e vi fanno
di decine di migliaia di ragazzi hanno
letto tu metti che trattano di queste
tematiche è iniziato un dibattito
ed è un modo per raccontare cose
complesse in modo semplice per iniziare
un percorso
ma non solo
con le storie quella cosa che noi
l'inizio non pensavano fosse essenziale
che cosa si fa
si possono vincere le elezioni
si possono vendere i prodotti
si può sempre più figli o meno figli di
quello che siete talmente sono potenti
le storie che i principali social
network che cosa hanno loro apparati le
storie oggi i ragazzi fanno lezione
dappertutto facciamo le storie perché
perché le scuole sono fondamentali
e arrivano al punto
al nocciolo del mio talk
voglio condividere con voi la mia
esperienza i miei obiettivi
che ho avuto sempre ben chiari e la mia
scelta coincide tutto perché io ho
deciso
di restare in questa città a messina e
fare il lavoro che io volevo fare da
quando avevo 5 anni
ci sono tre punti allora il primo punto
io lavoro con delle case editrici
nazionali e internazionali guadagni miei
soldi qui e li spendo qui e dunque c'è
un aspetto economico fondamentale in un
territorio dove purtroppo
l'immigrazione è una piaga disastrosa
non se ne parla né un'emorragia continua
io ho deciso di restare e dalle
richieste del territorio e vero sociale
culturale
economico secondo punto che ha a che
fare con la natura stessa delle storie
sapete
non è per la gente importante quello che
è vero
la verità no
quello è chi fa comunicazione lo sa
quello che veramente importante è che la
gente
creda che sia vera quella cosa oppure di
ripetere una storia furia di ripeterci
ma determinata cosa certo punto diventa
bene e la gente ci crede e si comporta
così forte che adesso viene
continuamente riscritta da chi vince lo
vediamo perciò mi sono detto io abito in
una città che ha una marea di storie
fantastiche che però per vari motivi
terremoti guerre
disgrazie vari abbiamo dimenticato in
buona parte alcune storie fantastiche
sono state dopo dimenticate perciò mi
sono detto bene visto che noi siamo le
storie che raccontiamo e poi ci crediamo
a quelle cose invece di raccontarci che
quella cosa è peggio ne che noi siamo
peggiore di quanto vediamo cominciamo a
prendere il meglio di quelle nostre
storie del nostro passato che abbiamo
dimenticato nella nostra memoria
ricominciamo prendiamo quelle radici
afferriamo le raccontiamo le io racconto
se posso e ho raccontato storie
ambientate qui
messina nel 1600 con caravaggio che
passeggiava quasi un uomo male il vespro
siciliano la storia di naka valenza
perché probabilmente se noi conosciamo
veramente chi siamo
e locali amo veramente
le nostre scelte nel presente
saranno più consapevoli e magari tutto
sarà diverso e magari ci ritroveremo
peggiori di quelli che pensiamo di
essere
importantissimo è stata infine
andiamo a chiudere sapete quando io ho
cominciato
da dire che quando volevo fare fumetti
da ragazzino è cominciato a fare fumetti
e diceva la gente bene che cosa fai tu
io faccio fumetti e giornaletti ai
giornaletti fumetti oppure
bene fai smetti bene ma di lavoro che
fai
io volevo dimostrare
che in un posto in cui non c'era nessuno
che faceva fumetti qui si poteva fare e
volevo far vedere alla gente ai ragazzi
agli altri non volevo che si trovassero
la mia condizione ma volevo fare vedere
che era possibile
ma di via roma a milano a londra nobile
a messina e come fare
faccio oggi con il loro smart working
possiamo noi siamo come chi si sente
smart working che oggi uffico lo smart
working ma la gente lavoriamo da casa lo
possiamo fare la fortuna di farlo scelgo
di farlo
che cosa mi è servito per fare queste
queste cose
quattro cose quando essenziali
una matita
un foglio di carta
le storie che creano la realtà
e dulcis in fundo
una buonissima granita caffè con panna e
brioche
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]